hey what's up guys my name is a chana
welcome back to my OpenGL Series today
I'm gonna be talking all about shaders
finally and we're finally going to be
able to actually see something on the
screen so last time we talked about
vertex attributes and before that we
talked about vertex objects that takes
buffers and all that stuff so definitely
check out those videos if you haven't by
just clicking on a link over there and
from last episode
some of you were actually able to
already see something on the screen and
if we dive into the code that we wrote
last time over here we've basically just
wrote these two lines if I try and run
this application as is without any any
kind of shade of stuff at all then
you'll see on my computer it actually
works and we do seem to see a triangle a
white triangle at our correct vertex
positions which we actually specified
over here so how come that's happening
and the answer to that is that some GPU
drivers will actually provide you with
the default shader if you haven't if you
haven't actually provided your own
shader and that was that's what seems to
be happening here but this is something
that is really really based on your
drivers right now I'm just running this
with the Intel drivers on this actual
laptop however I do also have an NVIDIA
GPU which will probably have to switch
to later for more serious things but
that being said it's completely driver
dependent so I don't really want to kind
of that that's why I didn't run it last
time and I really want to encourage that
because it'll probably end up working
for some of you but not for all of you
and then some of you will be like my
code doesn't work it's not really meant
to there's nothing in the OpenGL
standard that actually says you should
see a triangle if you write the code
that we've done right now that's
actually just up to the GPU
manufacturers to say hey you know what
if you don't provide shader we'll just
write a basic one for you so that you
can at least debug your code a bit
easier or something like that today
we're actually going to write our own
shaders so the first question on
everyone's mind is what is a shader a
shader is basically just a program that
runs on your GPU that's all that's all
you should be thinking of when you think
about a shader by program I just mean a
like a block of code it's code that we
can write as text as a string on our
actual computer then we can give it to
OpenGL we can send it to the graphics
card compile it like any other program
link it like any other program and then
run it like any other program but the
difference is that it actually is run on
our GPU on our graphics card and not on
our CPU like this C++ program yes so why
do we need program
to actually run on the GPU at all why
why do we have to write code and then
run it on the GPU well obviously we're
learning about graphics programming so
the graphics card does play a major role
in that but specifically the reason that
we want to be able to program the GPU is
because well we want to be able to tell
the GPU what to do we want to utilize
the power of the GPU to actually draw
graphics on the screen now that doesn't
mean that everything we do we need to do
on the GPU or should be doing on the GPU
in the form of a shader there are some
things that the CPU is still faster at
and as we kind of progress through this
series we'll probably find some things
that we will prefer to do on the CPU and
then maybe just send the result the
resulting data to the GPU while still
doing that processing on the CPU but
that being said there are undeniably
things a lot of things to do with
graphics that the GPU is simply going to
be way faster at and that's where
shaders come in handy now not just when
we want to defer things now now not just
where we want to kind of take things
from the CP or put them on the GPU but
fundamentally we need to be able to
program the GPU because even in the form
of drawing of drawing this really simple
triangle I still want to be able to tell
the GPU how to draw that triangle right
like where do the vertex positions go
what color should the triangle be how
should it be drawn all that kind of
stuff
right when we actually get into more
complex 3d scenes as well lighting is a
great example of why we want to be able
to program the GPU how does lighting
work all of that stuff I don't want to
get too ahead of myself but all of that
stuff needs to be programmed somehow the
GPU doesn't just know how to do this
right we need to tell the GPU what to do
with the data that we've sent it and
that is what a shader fundamentally is
now in this episode and for most of
OpenGL and for most of graphics
programming we're and you as well
probably going to be focused on two
types of shaders vertex shaders and
fragment shaders fragment shaders are
also known as pixel shaders by the way
so these two shader types are by far the
two kind of most popular ones and
probably the ones that you will be using
90% of the time there are other shader
types tessellation
Jada's geometry shaders that kind of
stuff compute shaders if you're doing
like completely kind of other stuff as
well there are many different types of
shaders don't think that there are just
vertex and fragment shaders that's it
you're done that's all that's all there
is there's much more and they do come in
handy when you kind of start getting to
the more advanced stuff and we will
certainly be covering those types of
shedders further down in this series
when we get to more complex graphics but
for now and for like 90% of shader
programming you're probably going to be
dealing with vertex and fragment or
pixel shaders right that's it so first
of all let's talk about what that
actually means what is the vertex shader
what does a fragment shader what are
they
why are there two types how do we use
them so now I haven't really covered the
OpenGL pipeline or the just a standard
kind of graphics rendering pipeline yet
but how does roughly work so really the
picture that you should be having in
your head is that we've written a bunch
of data on the CPU we've sent some data
to the GPU we've issued something called
a draw call we've bound certain states
as well before you showing that draw
call and finally we kind of get to the
shader stage of things or rather the GPU
gets to actually processing the draw
call and drawing something on the screen
and we get to see a triangle on the
screen that specific process is
basically the rendering pipeline right
how do we go from having data to
actually having a result on our screen
now shaders come in handy when the GPU
actually starts drawing its triangle and
vertex and fragment shaders are two
different shadow types that are along
that pipeline so when we actually issue
a draw call what happens is the vertex
shader will get called and then the
fragment shader will get cold and then
we'll see a result on the screen now
there are many things in between that I
have skipped over for simplicity's sake
there are many stages before the vertex
shader at many stages in between the
vertex and fragment shader as well as
between the fragment shader and the
restoration stage and all of that stuff
I don't want to really code out right
now I'm trying to keep this simple so
just keep that in mind all of you
advanced people who know exactly what's
going on but it's still watching these
videos for some reason I'm kidding by
the way pretty much everyone should
watch these videos because it might feel
in a lot of gaps that you're missing but
anyway the point being I am I am
simplifying this so we go from the draw
pole to the vertex shader to the
fragment shader to being able to see
on our screen now what the vertex shader
does or specifically the code that is
our vertex shader that gets that gets
called for each vertex that we're trying
to render so in this case we have a
triangle we have three vertices okay
that means that the vertex shader will
get called three times
okay one for each of vertex and the
primary purpose of a vertex shader is to
tell OpenGL where you want that vertex
to be in your screen space right so
where is so again simplifying is where
in your window you have a you have a
window open on your computer where
you're rendering these graphics where
would you like that don't that vertex to
be right that is what the primary
purpose of the vertex shader is just
again it has the word shader in there so
some people like to think of it like
having something to do with lighting or
shadows or no it's a program that's all
it is so this doesn't even have anything
to do with actual graphics traditional
graphics in terms of like color or
whatever all the vertex shader does is
it specifies the way you want the
positions to be now that being said it's
also used to parse data kind of from
attributes into the next stage and and
also in law in in our case the next
stage is the fragment shader so it's
also used for that because of course the
vertex shader will actually take in all
of the vertex attributes that we've
specified in our buffer in this case we
only have a position these positions
that we specified if we look back to our
code these kind of negative 0.5 and all
the all this actual this stuff we can
access this in our actual vertex shader
because we actually specify them as
vertex attribute pointers and you would
have noted that we also wrote the index
0 and this index 0 is actually going to
correspond to an index 0 which will
define in our actual vertex shader and
through that kind of format we'll be
able to actually access the data or
access this specific vertex attribute on
this specific virtual vertex attribute
being the position so once we've
accessed that position in a vertex
shader we can basically tell up in jail
I want you to position this vertex at
the position that we specified in the
attribute now you might be thinking this
is a very very trivial task like why
does this even need to exist obviously
we want to position our triangle or our
vertex position where we've actually
specified in our buffer well yes but
think about this what if you have a
camera you have a camera in a 3d world
and it's its position is somewhere
suddenly this these vertex position with
these vertex positions that we've
specified for our triangle aren't really
going to translate directly to being on
the screen at those same positions
because if the cameras moved then well
the triangle should move as well and
that kind of transformation of that
triangle needs to happen somewhere now
this comes down to certain things being
faster to do on the CPU and the GPU and
that's there's a lot of a lot of thought
that goes into this and we'll certainly
cover when we get off to writing cameras
and stuff like that
but all I'm saying is that don't think
of it it's not actually that trivial is
just saying that the dot of the dot the
data that is in my buffer that is where
I want my vertices to be because there
are certain transformations they
actually need to happen based on certain
states and just a lot of other stuff as
well but again the primary purpose of a
vertex shader is to provide those vertex
positions we need to be able to provide
some kind of transformation if if nests
if necessary so that OpenGL can actually
transform these numbers into actual
on-screen coordinates so that we see our
graphics in our window at the right
location in the right place
so once the vertex shader has run I
remember it runs for each vertex once
that's happened and we've run it in our
case three times it gets called three
times one for each vertex we move on to
the next stage in our pipeline in our
pipeline for this application which is
the fragment shader or the pixel shader
now fragment shape fragments and pixels
are a little bit different kind of
terminology we're not going to get into
that now but for now you can kind of
think of pixels as for our rather you
can think of fragments as pixels because
the fragment shader is going to run once
for each pixel that needs to get
rasterized what I mean by rasterized is
actually drawn on our screen so our
window is just basically made up of
pixels right it's like a pixel array
what needs to happen is those three
vertices that we've kind of specified
that make up our triangle now need to
get filled in with our
or pixels that's what the rasterization
stage is doing and the fragment shader
or the pixel shader is going to get
called one once for each pixel in our
triangle that needs to get filled in and
the primary purpose of our fragment
shader or our pixel shader is to
actually decide which color that pixel
is supposed to be that's all it does it
just it determines a color and output
color for our pixel so that we can get
so that so the people can get shaded
with the right color think of this as
like a coloring book where you've kind
of got an outline of things but you need
to actually color it any meter shade it
in with a certain color that's what the
fragment shader is responsible for now
straightaway you might have noticed a
difference between the two first half
shadow gets called three times fragment
shader might get called tens of
thousands of times right depending on
how much room our actual triangle
occupies on our screen if you have a
tiny triangle a really small triangle in
your window that might only get called
like another 50 times or something maybe
if it ends up taking up 50 pixels if you
have a giant triangle just filling your
window you know if in jail or something
like that you might it might be taking
up like I don't know a million pixels or
500,000 pixels or something like that
which means that that fragment shader is
actually going to get called 500,000
times immediately and I want you guys to
realize this even from the very
beginning that if I do something like
five times five equal like III calculate
what five times five is in the vertex
shader and the value of that is 25 that
calculation is going to happen three
times in in the process of rendering
this triangle because the vertex shader
gets called three times if we have a
huge triangle and we do five times five
that calculation in the fragment shader
and that fragment shader gets called
five hundred thousand times
suddenly we're doing five hundred
thousand multiplications and not three
there's a bit of a difference here right
which is why when it comes to when it
comes time to kind of optimize and think
about performance which is really all
the time you can probably start to
notice that hey it might be worth me
doing some of these critical operations
in the vertex shader rather than the
fragment shader and
you can pass data from the vertex shader
to the fragment shader as well so yeah
just something to think about just
wanted to mention that keep that in mind
fragment shader things in there tend to
be a lot more expensive because that
fragment shader is going to run for each
pixel that being said some things
obviously need to get calculated per
pixel so a great example I love bringing
up this example with fragment shader
specifically is lighting right if you're
calculating lighting each pixel is going
to have a color value that is determined
by a number of things for example the
lighting the environment potentially the
texture the material that's supplied to
the surface all of this stuff right
comes together to determine what the
correct color is for a specific pixel
obviously this is going to depend on a
number of inputs such as where the
camera position is and as I said all the
surface properties the environment
properties all of our stuff is going to
come together but in the end of the day
at the end of the day all you're
determining in the fragment shader is
the color of a single pixel that is what
the fragment shader does it's a program
that runs to determine which color this
pixel should be that's it once that
happens once that fragment shader gets
calculated your color will basically
make it to the to the screen okay to the
actual to your actual window that is
open on your computer and we'll see an
actual triangle why it's triangle in
this case because the the default shader
in this exam in our example in our
driver seems to be just a falling to
white which is probably the reasonable
default but anyway when we start writing
these shaders it will be whatever color
we specify so as an easy test we could
just say that hey every single pixel for
this triangle should be red and we
should just see a completely red
triangle okay
raccoon chatters wrong for each pixel I
may determine the color output vertex
shaders run for each vertex and they
determine the position on our screen
that is basically how shaders work now
you may think that I'm really over
simplifying things because I am making a
lot of the stages of the actual pipeline
and a lot of other shaders that we
actually have available to us but I
don't think I'm actually ever
simplifying at all that is actually as
simple as it is that being said you can
do some really cool stuff with this
right you have something that runs for
each vertex and fresh pixel width that
you can do like 90 percent of graphics
program
everything you see in games nowadays has
probably done 80 to 90 percent in those
shaders okay and believe me once you get
to some really nice looking graphics
those shaders could be thousands of
lines of code so they definitely get
very complicated not to mention that a
lot of game engines and certainly every
kind of serious big game engine actually
generates shaders on the fly based on
what's going on in your game and based
on what graphics settings you've
selected all that stuff so having like
kind of live shader generation and
compilation is very very common in game
engines so there's definitely a lot of
really cool things you can actually end
up doing with shaders anyway that's a
gentle introduction to shaders we didn't
get to writing any code this time but we
definitely will next time I just wanted
to give you guys a basic overview
finally kind of a bit of a technical
overview of what writers are how they
work what they used for and all of that
and hopefully we'll see them in practice
in the next episode one more thing I
want to mention is that like everything
else in OpenGL shaders work based on the
state machine which means that when you
want to enable a shader you're about to
draw a triangle and you want it to use a
certain shader to draw that triangle you
enable that shader
you might also send some data to the
shader so much like we're sending this
vertex data from the CPU to the GPU in
the form of a vertex buffer we can also
send data to our shader in the form of
something called a uniform and that
comes from the CPU as well so we kind of
set up all of that state enable the
shader and then we draw a triangle
that's how it works in OpenGL again like
the rest of OpenGL is pretty much just a
state machine you guys enjoy this video
you can hit that like button you can
also help support this series by going
over to patreon Ocampo slash to Cherno
really does help me make more of these
episodes and more quickly and all that
fun stuff you also get some pretty cool
rewards such as access to all the source
code for all of these videos kind of
episode by episode on github and plenty
of other awards as well just check out
that link if you want to discuss this
episode further I've got an OpenGL
channel on my discord you can head on
over and join that discord by going to
the channel calm slash discord is
basically just a nice community of
people where you can talk about C++ open
shell games all that kind of fun stuff
so definitely join by that link there I
will see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]